at thursday's town hall nbc moderator
savannah guthrie
finally finally asked president trump an
important question
that he's never answered that he refuses
to answer
a question that is that at the top of
everybody's mind
you were asked point blank to denounce
white supremacy
in the moment you didn't you asked some
follow-up questions who specifically
a couple of days later on a different
show you denounced white supremacy
for years but you always do it you
always start off with a
question you didn't ask joe biden
whether or not he denounces antifa
i watched him in the same basic show
with lester holt
and he was asking questions like biden
was a child
are you listening i denounce white
supremacy what's your next question do
you feel
it feels sometimes you're hesitant to do
so like you waited here we go again
it just feels like i know you've just
denounced white supremacy
five times but it just feels like you
don't wanna do you want will you do it
do you still beat your wife do you still
beat your wife there are no moderators
left
there are no moderators left at nbc
there are no moderators left
in the mainstream media there are no
moderators left
in our culture i'm michael knowles
that's the michael and all show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from last week from sunshine
cool water who says
it wasn't a smoking gun more like a
smoking
pipe oh that's not nice that has to do
with hunter biden story which which we
will get to because the hunter biden
messaging the media obviously are trying
to suppress this
they are not allowing it to be posted on
social media platforms
finally they had to relent a little bit
but they're still banning people for
posting about it
and you're hearing two things you're
hearing one this is false
russian misinformation and then on the
other hand you're saying
but some of the emails make him look
good he said well hold on wait a second
are the emails and the texts from hunter
biden
are they true or they false if they're
false and they're russian misinformation
that's one thing but if they're true
then we have to look into the
allegations but basically what they want
to say is
the the damning ones that talk about
hunter biden getting bought off by the
chinese
and by other people around the world the
ukrainians and selling his dad's
influence
those are fake but the ones that make
them look good those are real we'll
we'll get into what's real
it's very difficult the the
communication these days because
obviously there are a lot of people
who do not want to be able to
communicate the
real information that's going on in this
election now if you want to be able to
communicate in a very inexpensive and
effective way
you need pure talk usa okay if your
cellular plan
is with verizon at t t-mobile you are
simply paying
way way too much for the exact same
coverage that you would be getting right
now
with puretalk the average person who
switches to puretalk
is using less than four gigs of data per
month but the big carriers are charging
you
for unlimited data that is how pure talk
saves the average person over 400
per year on their wireless service for
exactly the same
network i know what you're hearing is
like well it's a similar kind of network
no
it's using the exact same network as one
of those carriers you get unlimited talk
text and two gigs of data all for just
twenty dollars per
month and if you go over your data usage
they won't charge you for it
how crazy is that it's unbelievable uh
head on over
you're just throwing money away right
now if you do not go to puretalk usa get
your mobile phone
dial pound 250 and say michael knowles
when you do you will save 50
off your first month dial pound 250
say keyword michael knowles pure talk
simply
smarter wireless
the town halls last week were very very
different
you had the trump town hall which was
actually a debate with the moderate
moderator quote unquote savannah guthrie
then you had the biden town hall which
was a total snooze fest
the reason we had the town halls at all
is because the democrats chickened out
of the presidential debates there was
supposed to be a second presidential
debate
but then the the presidential debate
commission insisted
that it be virtual insisted that there
be all these different safeguards
because trump had coronavirus a while
ago he's obviously doesn't have it
anymore
and so the the because the dems wanted
to chicken out they had these two town
halls instead which were not virtual
which were in person which
shows you what a lie it was that they
they used to try to get out of the
debates
the the town hall that president trump
attended
was much more hostile than any debate
could have been they realized that joe
biden can't string two senses together
so they decided to put in this
relatively younger woman savannah
guthrie to pretend to be a moderator but
actually to be the debate partner so she
opens up
this town hall where she's supposed to
be fielding questions from everyone in
the audience
she opens up on maybe the question
people care at least
about which is the timeline of president
trump
getting tested for coronavirus when was
your
last negative test when did you last
remember having a
negative test well i test quite a bit
and i can tell you that before the
debate which i thought it was a very
good debate
and i felt fantastically i was i had no
problem before
did you test the day of the debate i
don't know i don't even remember i test
all the time but i can tell you this
after the debate
like i guess a day or so i think it was
thursday evening maybe even late
thursday evening
uh i tested positive that's when i first
found out
back to the debate because the debate
commission's rules it was the honor
system
would be that you would come with a
negative test you say you don't know if
you got a test on the day of the day
no problem again the doctors do it i
don't ask them i test
all the time and did you take a test
though on the day of the day
you know if you ask the doctor they'll
give you a perfect answer i love this
exchange because of course nobody cares
about this at all trump says look i
tested positive on this day but that was
after the debate she says but when did
you test negative on the day of the
debate you say i don't know i test like
three times a day how am i supposed to
know
and she's trying to back him into a
corner where either he contradicts
himself or he tells some lie or you get
some doctor in the white house to say
he did take a test at this hour but not
at this hour some nonsense
so trump is just sitting there he's he's
pushing it out very well because he's
just
observing nobody cares about this other
than the media who are trying to entrap
him
so then when that when that path doesn't
work
when the the idea that trump gave the
virus to i don't know joe biden or chris
wallace which obviously didn't happen by
the way so the question is totally
pointless
then she starts to harangue him about
those stupid masks but
trump gives an answer here that he's
been a little off on some of the mask
messaging over the past six or nine
months
this answer gets to the heart of the
issue of the masks as president i can't
be locked in a room someplace for the
next year and just stay and do nothing
and every time i go into a crowd i was
with
the parents of our fallen heroes these
people are the most incredible people
and they came up to me and they would
hug me and they would touch me and
i'm not going to not let them do it
there was an event with the gold star
families the day after the supreme court
event with the most incredible people
you've ever seen
and i could have chosen not to talk to
him or to keep everybody away
and you know what as and i don't think
that's probably where
it was caught but maybe i was going to
say you bring it up you brought it up
yourself i mean are you
trying to suggest that do you believe a
grieving military family gave you covet
no i don't know where it came from and
you don't know where it came from and
the doctors don't know where it came
from
you're right you don't want to you want
to be a leader but you also are a leader
in a setter of an example
and if you're not wearing a mask when
your administration is saying best
practice right now is
wear a mask no it's not foolproof but
many people are catching it
so completely ridiculous line of
questioning first of all the
trump makes this point on the masks that
i think is hugely important
the masks are very very dumb they're
extremely dumb
i'm not making a scientific statement
i'm making a political and a
philosophical statement
the masks are dumb because we're humans
we're social creatures
we get a lot of our cues from how people
smile we like to see aren't smiles nice
we speak speech is the thing that makes
us
human and separates us from the animals
speech aristotle has written about this
oh
we've known about this for the whole
history of our civilization speech
and when you muzzle people and you cut
off their mouths and you block their
face and you view
individuals as though they're walking
piles of germs
that breaks down society and man is a
social creature
and i don't care if i don't care i
mentioned this on my show a couple weeks
ago
if you told me right now you can extend
your life by five years
or you can wear a potato sack over your
head for the rest of your life
you can you can you will live longer if
you
if you wear the potato sack or you can
shorten your life
by five years and not wear the potato
sack you know what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna i'm gonna take the i'm gonna
lose the five years okay because i want
to see people and i don't want us to all
view each other
like walking piles of germs now of
course that the scientific question
isn't
isn't even that dichotomy because as as
the cdc pointed out we mentioned this on
the show last week
85 percent of people who are testing
positive for the virus
report wearing their masks always or
often 3.9
of people who are diagnosed with covid
are saying that they never wear their
masks
so the issue of the masks is one that is
very complicated dr faucia said from the
beginning that people don't wear them
correctly which
makes it an issue there was the the
epidemiologist at columbia who told npr
that the reason the masks fail in
studies
is because people don't wear them right
so they're all these sort of scientific
issues but that's not the point trump is
making he's saying look
there's a grieving family that wants to
hug me i'm not going to tell them no
because of this stupid virus that has a
higher than 99
survival rate okay i don't even care
that i'm i'm older and i'm at a greater
risk and i'm the president of the united
states some grieving family wants to hug
me
i'm not going to say no germs go away
and what does savannah get she says
you're saying that you got covent from a
grieving family he goes no i never said
that what are you talking about
and then and then she hits another point
which is a key here
again not to the science but the
politics she says
your administration is saying to wear
the masks so why won't you wear the
masks
and and i just thought that question
sums up the left's view of politics
which is that our dually elected
representatives should have no say over
our politics
the administration should meaning the
bureaucracy meaning the deep state
meaning the
experts they should be able to tell the
duly elected president of the united
states what to do
i don't give a damn what the trump
administration is doing i didn't vote
for the administration i voted for trump
he's the guy that should have been his
answer there he's like oh yeah you're
gonna
i gotta listen to my subordinates i
don't think so
sister no way but i'm glad he's getting
to the point here because
if we go tit-for-tat over well this
study says the masks are two percent
effective well this study says the masks
are 50
effective it's just that's a losing game
who ca that's not the point
the point is what society do you want to
live in do you want to live in a society
where we're social again where we see
each other and we see smiling faces down
the street
you know there was a protest outside of
a nursing home
just last week and it was older people
saying the only thing we look forward to
are hugs from our loved ones and you
psychos
won't let us get them because of your
stupid
priorities and because you've outsourced
all of our political and philosophical
questions to a bunch of eggheads and lab
coats
who don't understand that i don't really
care i don't really care
about if i can extend my life an extra
six months but not ever get a hug or
or be near my family again trump
trump finally now getting that argument
that's the argument that i think we've
got to push
then of course savannah gets onto the
really really important issues you know
the issues that are at the top of it
much more than white supremacy even the
issues that are at the top of
everybody's mind namely
a meme going around the internet which
we will get to
but there you've you've got to recognize
here that there is good information
and there is pointless information all
over the internet okay and
we waste a lot of our time on the
pointless information but you can
occasionally get information that will
help your life and your business
namely expert ownership live
small businesses have taken a battering
since march okay many of them are still
feeling the effects of these lockdowns
jeremy boring who runs this ship over
here the daily wire
has talked about how the company was on
the brink
a number of times even when the company
was doing well it was on the brink
sometimes because all businesses go
through these kinds of crises
we're very excited to tell you that this
wednesday daily wire god king jeremy
boring is going to be presenting
alongside a team of world-renowned
business leaders at expert ownership
live
a two-day virtual conference about
leading through crisis
the conference features a lineup of
speakers such as leadership author john
maxwell
the founders of duck commander and
otterbox the benham brothers and many
others
who can relate to what entrepreneurs and
leaders are going through
right now they will share stories about
their own businesses startup journeys
the tough times that come along with
those with any
any company at all and how they were
able to come out the other side of a
crisis
stronger than they were before so right
now go to expert ownership live dot com
slash knowles wlas to register for 197
get a second ticket for a friend 50 off
you do not want to miss jeremy do you
maybe you do want to miss jeremy but you
always skip his if you i don't know he's
got a lot of wisdom you know so i would
check it out
expert ownership live dot com slash
knowles to reserve your spot this
wednesday for 197 dollars
get an opportunity to get a second
ticket for 50 off
this conference is one of those
investments in your business that you
will be very thankful for
later on down the road expert ownership
live dot com slash knowles
after all the ridiculous hectoring about
the
the masks and about the covid tests then
savannah gets into the real issues
because you know
what i think we're all we all want to
talk about right now
is q anon right we were supposed to
mention be
watching you on a debate stage right now
we're not doing that so let's clear up a
few things from the last one
hold it right there we are watching that
right now
we are watching a debate we're not
watching a moderated town hall we are
watching
some nbc democrat hack
grilling the president for at this point
it's been over 10 minutes at this point
she's still grilling the guy and
debating him
point for point but but we have to get
to that important question right i know
you wake up in a cold sweat in the
middle of the night you say
ah what is it what does trump think
about q anon
plea i need to know well good savannah
asks the question
frankly you want to know something i
denounce antifa
and i denounce these people on the left
that are burning down our cities that
are run by democrats who don't
while we're denouncing let me ask you
about q anon
it is this theory that
democrats are a satanic pedophile ring
and that you are the savior of that
now can you just once and for all state
that that is
completely not true
in its entirety i know nothing about
i just talked i know very little you
told me but what you tell me doesn't
necessarily make it fact i hate to say
that
that is very much the case it's funny
because before savannah asked the
question i thought oh cue anon
i don't really know what that is but you
know it sounds kind of kooky and so yeah
i totally reject that
but then she explained it she says
democrats are a satanic pedophile
ring and trump is stopping them and i
thought well
sort of sort of checks out to me uh
maybe where hold on where's the kooky
part
she's is obviously such a stupid
question so
the people they're dying to know you
think about cue anon you know this like
internet thing
and trump says well i don't know about
that and she goes well okay i'll tell
you
disavow it though and he's like well i
don't know i don't trust you you're a
liar
and i don't think anyone really cares
about the q anon thing so uh
no but you have to disavow it please
disavow it you must mr trump
of course q anon is not uh is not an
issue
by the way you know the minute that
trump disavows
q anon they're going to accuse him of
supporting satanism and pedophilia right
because
if q anon is anti-satanism and
anti-pedophilia then you know the minute
he says okay i disavow they're like well
why are you a pedophile
why do you support satan what are you
like what you just told me to disavow
it during this entire
exchange which by the way went on for 20
minutes
20 minutes before they took a single
question from the audience the whole
point was to go there
no debating just you start taking
questions from the audience in 20
minutes
there was a woman behind them this black
woman wearing a mask and she's sort of
nodding along
and the media were so upset that anyone
could even be seen to maybe
tacitly agree with trump that they
started going after this woman sarah
cooper is some blue check
chickie on on twitter tweets out a
parody of taken about a black woman who
follows trump around nodding and
everything he says
it's called token haha get it but it's
very fun to make fun of
black women who support republicans
because black women are supposed to be
owned by democrats
you're not allowed you're not allowed to
be a black woman and support a
republican that's wrong that's
we can make fun of you we can mock you
for your race we can mock you for your
sex we can mock you for
anything we white leftists because
you're ours you're supposed to be ours
you're not supposed to be conservative
cnn ran a whole segment furious about
this this woman
and they tried to insinuate that this
was a nefarious plot the fact that this
woman was there actually violated the
rules of the town hall
as the president was questioned on a
range of topics jolie could be seen
nodding as trump answered
despite the town hall event being billed
as an audience of undecided voters
julie is actually a trump supporter who
ran for congress as a pro-trump
candidate in 2018.
well they got him they got him then
right because this was supposed to be a
town hall for undecided voters and this
woman
they found out through their sleuthing
was a trump supporter
in 2016. now i know that it passed town
hall debates like with joe biden
they've they've had multiple undecided
voters who turned out to be biden
supporters of valid biden supporters
have spoken on air about how they
support biden
but that's fine we don't need to cover
that story
they got him dead to rights right they
got him this was supposed to be a town
hall for undecided voters
and the woman there supported trump
except oh except the town hall wasn't
for undecided voters
this audience looks a bit like america
it's divided
some here voted for the president in
2016 and plan to again
some support joe biden and some say they
are truly undecided we're going to get a
mix of questions on a range of topics
so oh some people there supported trump
like that woman
but cnn couldn't be bothered to google
it or maybe they did maybe they knew the
truth and they just wanted to lie about
it because when the story doesn't fit
their narrative
they just go on and make it up
that that was the tenor of the night and
trump did very well at this i thought
he did much better at this town hall
which was really a debate than he did at
the last debate
and i'm i suspect he would have done
better at a
joe biden debate than he would have done
at the last debate too incumbents
often lose their first debate i don't
think trump lost i just don't think he
didn't he didn't come off very well at
that because he kept interrupting
and it was he had a good strategy for
the first 10 minutes or so and then the
rest it kind of fell apart
but i think he probably would have done
much better at a second debate now
they're going to try to pull this debate
that the third debate away from them
they're already switching it so that
it's no longer a foreign policy debate
because joe biden just got nailed on
corruption in ukraine and in china so
they're saying well we can't talk about
foreign policy then
we'll move on from there meanwhile so
the trump town hall is going on there's
a biden town hall which was a complete
snooze fest
they went right into questions with
voters nobody there was no 20 minute
long debate before
before the town hall there was one
moment though that was really disturbing
which is
some woman stands up and says that her
little children are transgender
and wants to know joe biden's thoughts
on transiting little kids
and he he gave the wrong answer i'm the
proud mom
of two girls eight and ten
my youngest daughter is transgender she
isn't
she is she isn't a she i mean if she's
saying if this woman is saying that her
youngest daughter is transgender
what she's saying is she has a little
eight-year-old boy and she's pretending
that that little eight-year-old boy is a
girl
but the little boy isn't a girl the
little boy is a boy
barely capable of reason at age eight
well below the age of consent 10 years
below the age of consent
and this woman is an abusive mother
who's damaging her little son
and i don't know why she's doing that
but it is truly
truly awful and if there is ever a role
for the state
to get involved it's when parents are
abusing
their little boys and trying to pretend
that they're little girls
for whatever psychotic reason has
motivated them to do that in their own
adult heads obviously not very
well-formed adultheads
this is some sick stuff now probably by
the way the state would come in
with child protective services and take
your kids away from you if you don't
trans the kids if you don't let your
little boy who says he's a girl dress up
like a little girl
but of course in a just society the
opposite would be true so she she poses
this question she goes
what should i look i want to dress my
little boy up as a girl and have him
pretend to be a little girl
what are you going to do about that when
people say that that's not such a nice
thing
joe biden says you know i'm sorry you're
going through that
absolutely we should trans the kids how
will you as president reverse
this dangerous and discriminatory agenda
and ensure that the lives and rights of
lgbtq people
are protected under u.s law i will flat
out just
change the law every eliminate those
executive orders number one there should
be
zero discrimination and what's happening
is too many transgender women of color
are being murdered they're being
murdered there is no
reason to suggest that there should be
any
right denied your daughter or daughters
whichever
one or two one one your daughter that
your other daughter has a right to be
and do
none zero so you can tell joe biden
doesn't know anything about this issue
so he just goes back to the one talking
point that some staffer told him which
is
transgender women of color are being
murdered now
i know when you say that it sounds like
there's some epidemic of this in the
country but it's not the case it's
something like
20 per year 20 black men who are who
identify as women and usually when you
look into the individual cases it's
because
they're involved in prostitution or
something like that and are
are killed by black men who are either
didn't know that they were transgender
who knows i mean these are very very sad
cases but
they're very particular cases all right
this is not like this is happening to
millions of people per year or anything
like that but obviously it doesn't
affect this woman
she is very much a white woman and her
daughters or you know her son and her
daughter are not adults
this is this is not about whether adults
can choose to dress a certain way or
identify a certain way
this is about whether eight-year-old
children can be made to
look more like the opposite sex whether
you can block their puberty whether you
can shoot them full of hormones
whether you can castrate them whether
you can cross-dress them
this is some sick perverted stuff and
any reasonable society would stand up
and say listen lady i don't know what
you're doing to your kid
but stop dressing your little boy up
like a little girl when he gets older
when he
if he's 25 years old and he decides he
wants to put on a dress at night
that's his own business but you sure
shouldn't be doing that can you imagine
how confusing that is
to a little boy when i was eight years
old i wore a little batman cape around
birthday parties
and told people to call me batman
i'm very pleased my mother did not
indulge the fantasy that i wish she had
indulged the fantasy that i was a
billionaire that would have been great
i would actually okay maybe i'm
undercutting my own argument but
certainly if i thought i was a different
sex
that can be extraordinarily damaging but
what does biden know he just goes along
and he kind of makes these things up as
he goes
you tell he was grasping for the issue
he didn't even understand really the
question
and he does this on all issues you know
there's an answer that joe biden gave
on a matter of same-sex marriage
redefining marriage a while ago because
joe biden for most of his career
supported the traditional definition of
marriage and then around 2012 he decided
to flip on this and then he wanted to
pretend
that he's always been super duper gay i
don't know he's been very much in favor
of gay rights and redefining marriage
and all these things
so he's given this answer he's repeated
it a lot on the campaign trail and
something about it just doesn't sound
quite right i saw these two men in the
corner
when i was getting out of the car both
well-dressed men in suits
lean up and kiss one another and then go
their separate ways one went to the
hercules building and one went to the
dupont building
and i turned and looked at my dad just
looked at me said joey it's simple
they love each other it's simple joey
they love each other
what prompted me i let the president
know that
i i did not have to evolve at all
i was and my wife
my sister all of us we were way
not ahead but we it was never thought to
be a problem with us
that never happened i can tell you i
would bet the farm
i would bet every dollar to my name that
did not happen
two guys in the 1960s in the middle
of the center of delaware did not kiss
one another
because in those days it was
not publicly acceptable to do that and
they wouldn't have done even the guys
might have lived together might have you
know sort of done whatever
wouldn't have happened in public and i
promise you joe biden's dad didn't say
sonny
you see this perfectly choreographed
moment so that you can use
on the campaign trail 60 years from now
joey they love each other joe no i bet
i something tells me joe biden's dad who
was born what in like the late 19th
century or something early 20th century
was not this like open-minded liberal
guy who's like god joey you know
this is great and in 2012 you should
come out and
defend gay marriage even though you'll
vigorously oppose it for your entire
career
but then you can remember this moment
joey those guys love each other it
didn't happen and joe biden lies about
these things all the time don't forget
he had to drop out of the 1988
presidential race because he was a liar
he lied he's lied about horrible
personal events he lied about
the driver who got into a car accident
with his wife
this tragedy when his wife died he lied
about that guy
and after the guy died a guy felt so
horrible about it for his whole life and
then after the guy died he maligned him
based on nothing and said
that he was a drunk driver the atlantic
even called joe biden out on this story
so here's what joe biden could say you
could say yeah you know look i'm a
product of my age and i kind of don't
really have any beliefs but i went along
with it and so yeah
i opposed homosexuality for most of my
career and then i was okay with
homosexuality but i
supported uh i opposed redefining
marriage and then around 2012 i changed
my mind because it was more politically
expedient and i supported redefining
marriage and that's my career
and you'd say okay well that's true of a
lot of politicians so that's fine
whatever you know okay no big deal
but instead he's got to lie and say oh
yeah man i was
i was dancing to the village people back
in 1962 at the ymca
like no you weren't joe biden you
weren't doing that and none of that is
credible which is why when he gives
answers on anything forget
you know transiting the kids or or gay
marriage or whatever i mean when he
gives answers on taxes when he gives
answers on anything
you can't believe it because the guy has
no
principles the guy has no beliefs he was
giving an answer on police brutality
alleged police brutality and they said
okay well you know
what happens if a criminal is like
coming at a cop and is
a real threat or he's a threat to
another person you're saying the cop
can't use deadly force
and joe biden tries to split the baby
you can ban chokeholds you can
but but beyond that you have to teach
people how to de-escalate circumstances
de-escalate so instead of anybody coming
at you the first thing you do is shoot
to kill
you shoot them in a leg there's ways
biden 2020 shoot him in the leg
shoot him in the leg now anybody who has
worked in law enforcement anybody who's
ever shot a gun will tell you
that is very very poor form if you're
going to shoot you shoot
right into the guy right where you have
the best chance of hitting
shooting you know how hard it is to
shoot in the leg when somebody's running
away and what does it mean to shoot in
the leg you might
if you've got a dangerous situation
where you have to use force
who knows the other guy might have a gun
he might have a knife he could be
putting other people in danger you can't
do that
you've got to make a decision but joe
biden can't make a decision
because he doesn't believe anything and
he licks his index finger puts it up in
the air
and figures out which way the wind blows
after these silly back-to-back you know
side-by-side
town halls we find out that the
moderator who was supposed to moderate
that debate between biden and trump not
moderate at all
and actually turns out that he lied he
lied right through his
teeth which was a huge embarrassment to
the mainstream media and it's only going
to get worse
at the next debate which we will get to
in one second however
as with everything in 2020 there's been
a lot of drama you know around these
debates
but we are ready for the next and final
debate this thursday join us at 8 45
eastern 5 45 pacific
for an all-new episode of daily wire
backstage to watch the debate with us
and get our immediate live reaction to
this major political event and
even better join daily wire right now as
an insider or all access member
and get 20 off with code debate so that
you can watch all the debate coverage
live on our apple tv or roku app watch
the debate with us at dailywire.com
youtube facebook
get 20 off your daily wire membership
and not one but two leftist years
tumblers with code
debate when you sign up today head on
over we will be
right back with a lot more
so the moderator of the
[Music]
proposed second debate steve scully
found it came out that he was tweeting
he thought i think privately tweeting
with anthony scaramucci
to who is very anti-trump now before the
debate to talk about what to ask about
when this tweet came out steve scully
pretended that he got hacked that was
his big excuse
he says i was hacked this isn't real i'm
talking to the law enforcement right now
we're gonna find out what went wrong
turns out he didn't get hacked joe
lockhart at cnn tweets that quote
fact if steve scully says he didn't send
it you can take it to the bank period
anyone who questions him or makes
accusations is a damn liar
well guess what it turns out
once again cnn intrepid reporting
cnn was totally wrong the accusations of
everyone being a liar totally wrong
steve scully himself lied he was not
hacked
scully uh comes out and says for several
weeks i was subjected to relentless
criticism on social media and
conservative news outlets
regarding my role as moderator for the
second presidential debate
including attacks aimed directly at my
family i didn't see any of those attacks
buster and if if your argument is i got
some private emails or something
we all do quit whining give me a break
also you were
you were criticized for your role in the
debate because you were a joe biden
intern for goodness sakes and you worked
for ted kennedy in the press office
so yeah we didn't think you're much of a
moderator we don't think you're very
moderate and it's preposterous that
partisan dems moderate every single damn
debate including the one that fox news
hosts
fox news is supposed to be a
conservative outlet who do they put up
to be their moderator the democrat on
staff
so yeah we criticized you right
skellig says this culminated on thursday
october 8th when i heard president trump
go on national television twice
and falsely attack me by name falsely
maybe i don't know i don't know falsely
out of frustration i sent a brief tweet
to anthony scaramucci
the next morning when i saw that this
tweet had created a new controversy i
falsely claimed that my twitter account
had been hacked
then he goes and he says but i take
responsibility no you're not taking
responsibility you're blaming trump
that you colluded with an anti-trump guy
before a debate that you're supposed to
moderate
and then that you lied about it and said
that you were hacked and that somehow
that's trump's fault that's your fault
buster
that's your fault but you got caught you
got caught as a dem
hack and so what did you do you went
crying and complaining
so pathetic by the way it's not going to
get any better at this next debate the
next
moderator of a debate is also a huge lib
kristen welker
has deep democratic ties her parents for
starters have donated tens of thousands
of dollars to democrats over the years
this woman has been photographed with
barack obama all smiley smiley
and in 2016 this one was pretty funny
she gave
uh hillary spokesman jennifer palmeri
a heads up on interview questions that
she was about to ask
we go right to kristen welker kristen go
ahead he's
okay okay and i'm gonna ask you about
flynn
kristen go ahead you're live
kristen welker in the spin room i
believe she has the clinton
communications director with her go
ahead kristen okay thank you
i think this is his last question um
you know we have kristin walker we're
looking at her she couldn't quite hear
me before can you hear me now if you can
go ahead
hey ari i'm here with communications
director jen paul mary for the clinton
campaign
hey sorry i i was a little busy just
telling her exactly what i was going to
ask her and
kind of working on her answers with her
so i'm sorry sorry it took so long but
now we're going to get
to this real serious hardball interview
that woman on msnbc is going to be the
moderator of the next debate
why do we sign up for this part of the
reason we sign up for this is
conservatives is because we have no
institutional power even when we control
the white house we have no institutional
power so trump has to go on with the
savannah guthries of the world
sometimes there's an advantage to this
though it would be good i think if
president trump is going to interrupt he
should be more strategic about it
this week and he should focus more of it
on the moderator
who's not going to be moderate at all
and should let joe biden
try to finish his his sentences which
i suspect will not go very well at all
the other big event that happened over
the past few days is the women's march
remember the women's march
that was an event it was just a way to
protest trump in 2016
and a bunch of women went to dc and
screamed and
the women's march always built itself as
non-partisan it's the women's march you
know it's just for women it isn't about
trump this isn't about
abortion or whatever so this year some
pro-life women decided to show up
and uh turns out that women's march is
not really about women at all it's just
a bunch of leftists there was one
pro-life woman who showed up
pregnant and said look my baby
has a heartbeat my baby is obviously a
baby
and these ghouls over here want to kill
my baby but you should see the reality
of it that
my baby's a baby don't kill the baby
and one of these ghouls uh the pro
women's march you know the kind of
radical leftists there
said that this was so offensive that if
she were that baby
she'd want to kill herself imagine using
your child for political [ __ ]
what did you say you'd want to kill
yourself i'm saying if i was that child
i'd probably want to kill myself yeah
[Applause]
and why are you doing that to show
that my daughter is a real human
yes she's in my body yes i'm responsible
for her but
her life matters too and this march
they're not marching for pre-born women
that's why i'm here and my daughter's
here
makes perfect sense to me and you've got
this ghoulish leftist
gal saying yeah i'd want to kill myself
if i were that baby
yeah it's awful i mean that that's the
kind of uh women's solidarity we see you
saw it in the washington post
here's the headline women's march in dc
draws thousands in protest of supreme
court nominee
the supreme court nominee who who i will
remind you is a woman
and what a woman oh my god this one you
know truly talk about having it all
right this woman incredible judicial
career incredible academic career and
mother of seven
five biological kids two adopted kids
now put up for the supreme court oh my
gosh the women should be thrilled right
they should be
gathering in support of this woman but
they're not because this march has
nothing to do with women it's just a
bunch of leftist schools
shouting disgusting things such as if i
were
a baby in that pro-life woman's womb i'd
want to kill myself
also also don't forget as we have this
re
this ritual in the liturgy of liberalism
that happens now i guess once a year
thousands of people showed up for this
women's march
and yet many thousands of churches in
the country remain closed
now something tells me covet is going to
spread just as easily
with all these thousands of people
gathered together protesting for liberal
causes
as would in a church where we spread
more quickly but it doesn't matter
from the very beginning there's one set
of rules for leftists on the coronavirus
and another set of rules for everybody
else you can't go to grandma's funeral
but you can go to george floyd's funeral
doesn't matter that only 50 people are
going to go to grandma's funeral and 100
000 are going to go to george floyd's
funeral
it's important for the liturgy of
liberalism that everyone go to george
floyd's funeral
that's that's a religious liberty issue
but your religious liberty your religion
no way there's a caste system now in
america and
sorry buddy you're not at the top of it
actually as a matter of these kind of
racial grievance politics we've got an
a brand new political party in the
united states not kanye west's political
party the birthday party which i'm
probably going to join
after the trump years i'll probably just
end up leaving the republican party
joining the kanye west birthday party
say what michael what is your political
view i'm a kanye west conservative
more of a kanye kind of guy but p diddy
puff
diggity doo dad uh was the one who just
came out and formed a new political
party
called the black party our black party
he tweets out quote the number one and
this is kind of all random
capitalizations the number one priority
is to get trump out of office he has to
go
by the way puff daddy used to be friends
with trump there are a lot of pictures
of them hanging out having a good time
but i guess trump becomes a republican
all of a sudden
p diddy can't lose his street cred he
has to go we can't allow this man to
continue to try and divide us
the people that have the most
responsibility and should be scared to
death of this man
or white people we're on the verge of a
race war
what does that mean i guess that's a
threat say white people should be really
scared because we're on the verge of a
race war
however it does occur to me
more white people than black people in
the country right i mean white people
are what like 50
more than 50 percent of the country and
then black people are like 12
of the country so what does that mean we
you should be scared to death of this
man because we're on the verge of a race
war
i hope we're not on the verge of a race
war things have gotten too serious it
would be irresponsible of me to have us
hold our vote hostage
ah and there's there's the key it would
be a responsibility to have us hold our
vote hostage
but it would also be responsible of me
to let this moment go by and not make
sure
going forward we're doing what it takes
to own our politics wow that's so lame
so he goes i'm starting a new political
party it's only for black people because
trump is dividing us so i'm going to
make another political party that
divides us on the basis of race
but you know it's very important that
the whole black party
votes for biden the democratic party
well then you didn't make a new
political party you're just
it's just a pr stunt for the democrats
it's very important that we be
independent and think for ourselves and
do exactly what the democrats tell us to
do
um no i don't think that makes sense at
all
you know the the other political party
that was just formed the birthday party
my favorite new political party at least
for kanye i mean he likes trump but he's
he is kind of forging his own political
identity
he's saying yeah i disagree with the
republicans on this i disagree with the
democrats on this
it actually is his own kind of thing and
for a lot of it i actually agree
pretty wholeheartedly with the kanye
west birthday party but the the black
party from p diddy doesn't mean anything
he's just saying yeah
yeah we're black people are going to
have our own political party and then
we're going to
immediately rejoin the democratic party
and actually we'll never have left in
the first place
that's democracy for you you know some
people are really afraid of losing our
democracy
because if trump wins by definition that
means that we're losing our democracy
there was a i felt
one of the most articulate leftists in
the country just summed this up on
social media
terrified listen to me republicans
listen you are the people in history
they warned us about
they warned us about people like you
pay attention we're losing our democracy
wake up wake
up
can i file a workman's comp claim for
what just happened to my eardrum
because that we should have turned that
down before that lady gave her beautiful
oration
uh but i think her her point expresses
the views of many democrats in this
country
and it's it's one of the funniest ones
they never seem to realize the irony of
this
they come out and they say look we
support democracy
and if you ever if you the people ever
disagree with us
that's the end of democracy so well hold
on
you're saying that you support the
people going out and expressing their
views
at the ballot box and that's good
because that's pro-democracy but if they
ever disagree with your
party the end of democracy but no
i think in in reality that would be an
expression of democracy wouldn't it
this is something that that liberalism
and the democratic party just doesn't
understand
because they don't support democracy
they are progressive and so they believe
that well one being part of the
progressive project they believe most of
our politics should just be outsourced
to experts and bureaucrats and eggheads
and the administration so they give all
difference to that but even at the
ballot box
for what little that means these days
because we're
we're on the road to progress the
democratic party has to win
it has to it's it's the only it's in
everybody's interest
it's what all the smart people want to
do and it's what all the good people
want to do
and if anybody just knew the facts they
would vote for the democratic party
so any any time the democrats lose it is
by definition
illegitimate according to them any
the only way it makes sense is if
democracy has been subverted
i mean this is what's really led to the
problems of the the trump era
is the democrats told us that trump is
hitler right because they thought it was
going to be easy to beat him so they
said trump is hitler
and then half the country voted for
hitler
so either half the country are nazis or
they were wrong about trump or lying
about trump
or some combination but that the left
can't admit that they were wrong or that
they were lying it's not they're not
capable of it
and so it has to be the case that half
the country are nazis now they're
proposing a truth and reconciliation
commission just like they had in south
africa
to to basically just to punish everybody
who voted for trump there are multiple
democrats proposing this on msnbc
major democratic economists they're
proposing this because it is not
legitimate
in a democratic system to vote for
anybody other than
the left those are the stakes of this
election
there is no moderation there is not none
left there are no moderators you know
it's fun the moderator the term
moderator
comes from the word the moderate the
idea to to bring down
to lessen to get into control to make
less extreme
to be modest to to be there's nothing
modest or moderate
about frankly about most people left in
the country but certainly about the left
there's none of that so there is there
is no moderator
we won't we won't have that and and i i
do fear as a result
however this election turns out
there might not be very much
reconciliation unless people do get a
little bit of that modesty or a little
bit of humility or a little bit of
charity for their fellow
americans cool down the screaming in the
shouting
and recognize that uh there are reasons
that people would vote for democrats i
mean they're bad reasons and it's
immoral to vote for biden but
people make mistakes this is a fallen
world and the democrats need to realize
that there are reasons for people to
vote for trump
such as wisdom and moral clarity
and you know intelligence and other
reasons too
education and they they need to
recognize that because
if you if you believe just that by
definition
anyone voting for the other guy is has
undermined the entire system
then the system's over and that creates
a very precarious situation
as we head in within just the next few
weeks into an election that may already
pose
a constitutional crisis that's our show
i'm michael knowles the michael knowles
show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva and production assistant
ryan love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
you know the matte wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll give it a listen